so hopefully I won't get sued for this
but um if you understand what's playing
in the background right now you will
understand and you've heard me talk
about this many times but once again I
continue to read my email because I
loved the peeps that you know me thank
you so much I'm trying it's hard to
scale one person for sure and after
reading a boatload of them on my flight
from Miami to New York last night I felt
compelled you another garyvaynerchuk.com
because yes my tune will not change I am
convinced that people do not understand
that it takes patience and a long time
to build a real business 18 months of
blogging or putting up a website or
having a business it's not enough time
to retire and go lay on the beach for
the rest of your lives
Mott and everybody else it just blows my
mind that people don't get it it takes a
long time now you don't need to be naive
head in the sand and not recognize if
what you're doing is good or not but if
you have steady traction you don't need
to win the lotto
you know you absolutely have to grind it
out your grandparents do or
great-grandparents didn't come to this
country and after two years expected to
have it all our skin has gotten really
thin and people are just giving up way
too fast I don't know if it's because
parents are nicer to these days mom and
we just think everything is cush cush
it's not cush cush you've got to work
your ass off you've got to be good
you've got to create good content you've
got to give great customer service you
have to be better than your competition
and most of all you really need just a
little actually you need a lot
Guns'n'Roses was wrong Axl Rose is wrong
you need a boatload of patience because
it takes years to build something that
actually sticks and is a real real real
business not a fly-by-night scam or
concept